[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight this is the tenth day in
a row that we have devoted a large
portion of this show to Brett Kavanaugh
a Supreme Court nomination we've done
that because this story matters and not
simply because the Supreme Court itself
matters the way Kavanaugh has been
treated by Democrats in the Senate as
well as by the media and the left-wing
interest groups would be the only do
their bidding in concert gets the most
basic questions about what kind of
country we want to live in does every
American deserve to process are the
accused presumed innocent rather than
guilty dis fairness still matter in this
country well it's all of those we'd
answer yes the left are used no to them
acquiring power justifies anything
that's the real debate here we thought
you should know that and after the day's
developments in there are many after
yesterday's hearings it seemed that this
debate must be drawing to a close it's
hard to imagine watching what Brett
Kavanaugh said to the Senate yesterday
without feeling profound sympathy this
is a deeply sincere man who believes
that his family has been destroyed by
false and unsupported allegations many
wept as they watched him speak
Democrats remained unmoved some argued
that Cavanaugh's anguish was itself
evidence that he is a monster as if only
a sex criminal would recoil at being
called a sex criminal he did so is both
a calendar and a diary it's a very
organized guy to put it mildly
well that was the wrong soundbite but
you get the point Barbara Boxer
explained today that his anger onstage
made her think he was capable of
violence would you be angry if they said
that about you but no matter what they
say Democrats don't mean any of this
personally they don't hate Cavanaugh or
his family they don't seek to destroy
either one they're just irrelevant
Democrats just want to be in control so
yesterday they immediately began
stalling for time and they did that by
demanding a seventh FBI investigation
into Brett Kavanaugh his life the point
was to run out the clock on his
nomination they continued that tactic
today at two different hearings and
especially in the afternoon when the
Senate Judiciary Committee reconvened
watch this I cannot sit here I cannot
participate and what I know the history
is gonna look back as a dark moment
again in the same way we look back at
the Anita Hill Clarence Thomas drawers I
cannot participate that to again
relegate ourselves to what I believe is
a dark dark element of our society so
that sir I will leave
well that was New Jersey Senator Cory
Booker a man so oily he qualifies as an
alternative-fuel almost nobody who knows
Booker takes him seriously but today he
found an ally surprisingly among
Republicans that was Jeff Flake of
Arizona flake had declared that he would
be voting for Cavanaugh's nomination
then he was confronted by a mob of
screaming protesters the youth wing of
the Democratic Party you are someone who
is unwilling Court of the country and to
and to have the role of repairing the
harm that has been done in this country
to many people no no thank you
I understand but tell me I'm standing
right here in front of what do you have
do you think that he's found the truth
don't know Wow that man looks afraid and
ashamed you don't often hear senators or
see senators look like that this kind of
thing has been happening a lot in
Washington it happened to Ted Cruz when
he found himself surrounded by red
guards like these at dinner he left the
restaurant Jeff Flake crumbled flake
announced that he would not approve
Cavanaugh's nomination without
additional FBI investigation
Democrats cheered his change of heart
quote I applaud Senator Jeff Flake
decision to rise above the partisan
circus on display during this entire
process
harrumph twist for jigna Senator Joe
Manchin of course in Washington when
they congratulate you on leaving the
partisan circus chances are you are now
the ringmaster of the partisan circus
and of course Jeff Flake is exactly that
so what does this mean going forward
well factually it doesn't mean a lot the
FBI does not want this case there is
nothing to investigate here and they
have said that pretty definitively
already weeks ago Dianne Feinstein sent
them Christine Ford's original letter
and that was their response this is not
a federal criminal investigation it
cannot be no federal crime has been
alleged only police in Maryland can
conduct an investigation into this and
they're not because strangely christine
ford has never filed charges against
Brett Kavanaugh in the jurisdiction
where she says this took place instead
the FBI FBI will conduct what is called
a supplemental investigation agents will
interview only those directly connected
to Christine Ford's original allegation
in this case that would amount to
Christine Ford and Brett Kavanaugh of
course along with the three people Ford
says were present when she was attacked
in 1982 that would be Mark judge PJ
Smith and Leland Kaiser the problem is
that all five of these people have
already given sworn testimony yurov
aware of what they've said four of them
have categorically denied under oath
Ford's version of the story if they
deviate from their previous testimony
they could face criminal penalties so
what could we possibly learn from having
the FBI interview them keep in mind that
the FBI makes no judgments in these
investigations it does not assess credit
does not render any kind of conclusion
it just does interviews and then it
summarizes them for lawmakers the FBI no
matter what they're telling you is not a
tiebreaker in this or any other
investigation
it's an investigative agency that will
provide the Senate with information that
Senators already have so Brett Kavanaugh
is gonna get interviewed again you
probably have to get a prostate exam to
be more thoroughly vetted than Cavanaugh
has been in the last 20 years so they
may try that too if you're looking for
truth this would be an utterly pointless
exercise you wouldn't consider it but
the truth is not what anyone is looking
for here as you may have figured out
Democrats are hoping that more baseless
allegations will emerge during the delay
during which the FBI is investigating
things that have long been investigated
perhaps another reptilian porn lawyer
will come forward with another
discredited client who describes
fantasies of I don't know gang rape or
human sacrifice or child trafficking
maybe it'll be ritual satanic abuse this
time they haven't tried that one in a
while who knows what it'll be but when
those charges emerge Democrats will
demand new public hearings on every
single one of them democracy hangs in
the balance they will tell us meaning
their access to power hangs in the
balance it's not a complicated formula
and everyone in Washington knows exactly
what's going on here except for maybe a
poor Jeff Flake people who know flakes
say he may actually believe Democrats
are acting in good faith or maybe he's
auditioning for a new employer he's
leaving the Senate early next year
either way you'd have to be an idiot to
think that caving to this demand will
induce Democrats to call off their smear
campaign against Brett Kavanaugh and his
family they won't they'll accelerate it
why wouldn't they it's working but
there's a cost especially for
Republicans at this point Cavanaugh
isn't just a Supreme Court nominee he is
a folk hero to many people an
inspiration to millions people who've
spent the last two years being
browbeaten and bullied by their moral
inferiors were buoyed by what he said
yesterday these are people who've been
told they are worthless and bigoted
they've been unfairly maligned because
they are in the way of other people
gaining power
they've been commanded to shut up and
obey Cavanaugh stood up for those people
yesterday he raised a middle finger to
their torment
and they love him for it Cavanaugh is
far more popular with Republican voters
tonight than any single Republican
senator and he's incalculably more
popular than the Senate as a whole
Cavanaugh probably wouldn't describe it
this way but he now has a constituency a
powerful one and they will long remember
whether or not Republicans defend him in
his moment of need